Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Four Last Things.
well actually we've got six last deadly sins to commit before the
end of the game, but I gotta start using the items that I have
Amongst the various people now I could probably chisel and mallet one of these statues
Can I?
The tools are blunt
But try anyway, you didn't even give it a shot. Can I chisel and mallet that asshole there this guy?
Yeah, that doesn't need to be chiseled or melted you never know until you try alright. You want a new loot. Hello?!
Do you want a you want a jam (hahaha) do you want to jam? sure what do you want to play?
Do you know the witches dance John wands can she excuse my wrongs anything by Orlando D'Alessio, uhm how about the witches dance?
Let's do that one sure do
( Guitar Music)
Huehuehue
this is Lovely I guess it's very lovely i...
Wonderful actually, so yeah sure okay, alright. Well oh
Good do I have a choice in the matter? I I can't even skip this all right. Well. I guess we're just committed here
Okay, we're done you play good for a gutter pleb, Thanks? What happens if I do the other one
Uhm
John Dallin scan she excuse my wrongs of course
(Guitar Music)
Oh
Baby that is a sweet something oh, that's good. Oh, yeah, I like that oh
Yeah, oh
Yeah, ah
Say it slower, that's a good stuff
Oh yeah
Okay, well there was no point in that. Thank you alright. Hey. Do you need a hammer and chisel dude?
Blacksmith you need this. Can you sharpen my chisel, please good, man. I don't usually work for free in fact
It's kind of disrespectful for you to even ask. what if I ask really nicely? What if I promised to pay?
What if I do a sexy dance for you?
Hey pretty good that what if I do a sexy dance for you, then at least we'll both be degrading ourselves. Ha
Hue hue hue hue (xD)
Ha, okay, this is getting weird alright, pass me the chisel alright
Hands on fire dude alright well, never mind I guess he's fine alright. Thanks. Thank you. Hey
I'm doing pretty good!
This guy, what do you think of my progress so far and I guess skedaddle over here can I do this now?
use chill it and mallet to craft stats you have lead in the Swan mess of yourself expression of inner turmoil crude copper I
Gotta go with the crude copper phallus. I'm pretty sure that's bronze also no, no no really
Oh Come on, alright expression of your inner turmoil
...
(o.O)
Tumultuous!
why is there an owl! why wait why is their torsos like an acorn!?
What's coming out of them is that branches or tentacles or insect legs? What's with the testicle little like any of that.
I'm a master sculptor apparently that okay uhm
Lleida and the Swan.
...
Oh beautiful nice boobs I have to censor that great radiant
Oh beautiful fine art is lovely, how about a statue of myself?
There's no doubt I deserve a statue for my work in the field of indolence and neglect
But I have no idea what I look like the establishments are frequent
Don't tend to boast many reflective surfaces if I'm gonna make a statue myself. I'll need some reference material
Oh! i know how to do that
But I don't know what to do for the loot hmm, maybe if I play a loot for this guy
Yeah, you want he's clearly a horns guy. I'm not messing with his vibe
Okay, anybody want to give me some money anybody want to give me some money for this amazing Luke work
I don't think they're interested well alright, then let me at least change this so it doesn't need to constantly be censored
inner turmoil alright
It's good stuff
What about the rich landowners you think they would want some they like Loudoun zing about?
Can I give you some hey buddies? Hey give me money?
Hey dudes. Get me money. You want to give me money? money?
oh, That is not me playing (hahaha) i don't know what's happening there.
I don't think they're in...
(2 hours later...)
That was splendid marvelous effervescent divine, okay, okay enough you guys are really the worst
Hey, you gave this game developer money. Why can't you give me some money? Why is you why this?
old man with pig
Nice pig that pig is really nice, and I like the way it looks and I hope it feels
Like good company for you
Yeah, you know what you think? lame?
oh, ffffuck you (hahaha)
Fuck you man and your pig
By you music is a man-made creation
I draw only inspiration from the work of God how about you?
Shove your pen right up your anus gotta be away. There's gotta be a way
Who's someone appreciate my music.
dog?
Dog please I'm desperate
I need money so badly and if money so so badly I need it. I need it
Dog oh shit, I'll pray for you
Mmm
Since I lost my sight my other senses become heightened I feel every strum of your lute like a wave breaking over my naked body
It takes all my strength to remain sane in the face of this onslaught of pleasure well
That's weird, not to drown in the sea of your music
rad
Can I have some money for that? Maybe give us some money?
Pie King would you like a serenade?
Will you get lost in the pleasure of my lute my pickle fingers will make it real good for you?
Music is for sissies. Well. You are just a raging asshole
Hey, can you stop fighting for one second and appreciate my art that'd be great
(ugh) Alright, I'll hammer and chisel the shit out of this thing
It's a statue of a fat dwarf riding a donkey nothing I, or anyone else can do to improve it
Well, shit. (:D)
Deedle, da, doodle, de da
So I gotta find there's gotta be a way that I can get some goddamn coin
The only the people that I know of around here would be the party goers from the other scene
Okay, I'm going I'll get there everybody shut up. I ain't gonna look up a walk through cause I aint a cheater
I'm gonna get this just also because it's fast and hitting like this game is oddly fascinating
I just am in love with the style of it
It's bold choice to be honest. what was in here again?
oh Yeah that's right, I meant to go in here before, I'm a dummy. hello This guy's loitering by the door (slappa)
That's what you get for loitering. Please don't do that again, It's happening. (slappa) It's your worst nightmare. It's a bunch of slaps
(slappa)
It slaps giving up in here alright. Hello. How you doing?
What is this place? This is the chief Clerk's office all the town's administrative paperwork has looked after here. Who are you?
I'm a disreputable looking corner loiterer
You don't look that disreputable to me well technically I am employed by the chief clerk, but not in an official capacity
Alright, can you help me find a document I can but you'll have to answer my riddle first
Alright, why do you ask people to answer a riddle we prioritize intelligent inquiries the riddle weeds out the imbeciles
Okay, I will answer it now. alright here it is. I'm the one who gave you life, but not your father and not his wife
(ok then...)
My powers are great, but are not godly. I made your head, but not your body. Who am I?
Wah wah
Woah, woah, woah, waha
That goes down a while
(The heavens open!)
Nobody
Nobody is not the correct answer. Can I hear the riddle again?
your grandparents... ugh
Well, I am very dumb apparently I'm one of those imbeciles
hieronymus
van
hieronymus Van Hema Singh
Ah, apparently that's not the correct answer. Okay, alright. Good old scribble. He's having a good old scribble
Please don't disturb this clerk when they're working all right excuse okay. Hello sort of a magician
He doesn't look very busy his work involves deep concentration and mental calm try to figure out how many of it could possibly matter.
See he's trying to figure out how any of it could possibly matter it probably doesn't, but it seems important somehow
So I'm a double checking my work
please don't disturb um
Okay, alright, then doodly-doo dude. Okay. Hello. How you doing? He's engrossed by that document
Okay, wait who's talking here?
Excuse oh you. Oh, you okay, arrogant looking at end don't even think about it. I was talking about excuse me
What do you want?
What is this place chief Clark's office all the town's administrative paperwork looked afterwards here? Who are you?
I'm in attendant. Can you help me find a document the chief clerk office is very busy right now. I'm not asking the clerks
I'm asking you. I'm very busy right now. I have pressing matters to attend to yeah, it seems like it at the moment
I'm engaged in the task of convincing you to piss off
I won't be free to handle further inquiries until you piss off so piss off (rude)
Well, that's stupid
Iran amiss boss that was one of the names that I was gonna list off Hieronymus Bosch
Yeah, but that wouldn't be at the Garden of Earthly Delights this doesn't even make any sense
Wait a minute is one of these things like
wait...
Pending a man with a strangely familiar body....
Hieronymus Bosch are they wait are these all Hieronymus Bosch wait
Jacob van Utrecht wait made your head, but not your body
o.o
Jacob van Utrecht
Wait a minute strangely familiar your body strangely familiar. Head. I made your head, but not your body
My power is great. But not godly Jacob van Utrecht. You talking about Jacob van Utrecht
You talking about Jacob van Utrecht (by george i think he's got it)
you talking about, you talking about Jacob van Utrecht? are we talking about Jacob van Utrecht over here
We're talking about Jacob van Utrecht. man how would I have ever been able to get, Jacob van... and here
I was think it was like a logical answer to a riddle but apparently not
Jacob van Utrecht yeah, this definitely general knowledge everyone will be able to get it
looking for Jacob van Utrecht.
Jacob van Utrecht! (words?!) Jacob van Utrecht
alright, okay, how about
Jacob
Jacob van Ut that's not right... van eyck
what the..
Jacob van Utrecht! wait Oh more MORE van Utrecht, van Utrecht! Jacob van Utrecht! correct!
What documents are you looking for copy of the town's official treachery deceit an extortion regulation no problem?
I have that right here. I feel like we could have saved a lot of time
You could just ask me what I want in the first place, but thanks. Okay, cool way to go.
I did it. I got something (YAY)
Amazingly I got something okay. I got this for you. Can I have some money?
Great, I'm really doing all able to squeeze every last penny out of these saps now. here's your cut
Nice doing business with you. hey!
What did I do?
greed :D
Yes!
Yes, I have!
yes, I have (...)
All right, oh hell. Yeah. Oh hell to the yeah, okay
Any minute now I get it I get it I get it
Okay, there. We are
Oh, yeah, yeah, how much money do I get how much money well great riches
I've got so many riches. I'm gonna go over to the painter. and I'm giving some great riches
How many is my great riches? is this just like two pence? is it two pennies?
is it two pennies? either way. I'm gonna get my painting. here..
Paint me. Would you paint my portrait? Now? Okay? Take a seat?
now tell me what you look like I
Am a man. (...a man...)
....
Emerging resplendent from a shimmering lake! (...Emerging from a lake...)
I have dark hair and dark eyes (...dark hair dark eyes...)
I'm wearing a turk... No. I'm wearing a..
I AM COMPLETELY NUDE!!! (XD)
These are my tasteful nudes Babu a nude I may be a blind, but I'm a respectable portrait painter. I don't paint smut dang
Oh come on fine. I'm not naked
All right, I am a homunculus a homunculus
I'm
Riding our horse into battle. I have light hair and dark eyes I am
Wearing a white dress yellow cardigan slip-ons may be blind, but I paint from life not from the imagination
I'm imagine you have described doesn't have any ring of truth to it. Okay fine then god damn of course
Mmm, mr.. Stickler for it and whatever. I'm a man I
Am sitting on chair right in front of you a chair dark hair and dark eyes
turquoise jacket
I'll see what I can do done oh
Hey
Thanks. It's lovely all right. I just learned that I'm hideously ugly, but I know what to do with this now for summaries
I'm gonna get my vanity on I think that's probably what it is something like that vanity
Maybe I don't know there we go. Oh, I've got a ugly worth. Okay. Pop this bad boy on their craft tattoo myself
There's no doubt I deserve a statue for my own work in the field of indolence and neglect
But I have no idea what I look like oh
well I have it I
Have it oh
There we go now. I have some reference material. Okay, all right here. We go of me. Make you love me oh
Yeah
Marvelous oh god. Yeah, yes yes yes
Yes
Yes pride. Yes, oh
Yes, I'm beautiful you guys are seven look at me and just go like man that guy
He knows how to put his face together, and that's all I am every day looking at myself
I'm goddamn gorgeous all right so anyway
I got two more deadly sins and I bet the next two sins are gonna cap lapis clap okay. They're gonna come so easily
So thank you everybody so much for watching. I'm gonna continue playing this game
It's super fun
And let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye